the ellen degeneres show is facing new
allegations this morning of rampant
sexual misconduct
and harassment in the workplace the new
accusations reported by buzzfeed news
come just two weeks
after another article on the site
detailing a racist and toxic work
environment
degeneres responded thursday before the
new article was published
apologizing and taking responsibility
for what happens
at the show warner media is also
conducting its own
internal investigation jamie yukis has
more on the allegations
dozens of former staffers of the ellen
degeneres show which is known for
promoting kindness
when i say be kind to one another i
really mean it are sharing new details
about alleged
inappropriate behavior behind the scenes
by senior managers
christy yandoli with buzzfeed news broke
the story
so former employees who worked on the
ellen show told me that they experienced
a range of sexual harassment and
misconduct and witnessed a range of it
from sexually explicit comments to
behavior and inappropriate unwanted
advances
before the articles released thursday
night the show was already facing
scrutiny after several former staffers
described a culture of racism fear and
intimidation in an earlier buzzfeed
article
employees told the publication they were
fired after taking medical leave
or bereavement days to attend family
funerals
another former employee said she walked
off the job after becoming fed up
with comments about her race she said a
head writer came up to her at
a party and said oh i only know the
names of the white people who work here
in a letter to her staff obtained by cbs
news thursday
degeneres said she'd hoped the show
would be a place of happiness
where everyone would be treated with
respect and was disappointed to learn
that this
has not been the case she also said the
show was taking steps to correct the
issues
i've spoken to nearly 50 former
employees who worked on the ellen show
all of them
say they found what their experience was
behind the scenes to be
in contrast to what the show
makes a profit off of and what ellen
degeneres has built an entire brand off
of which is the be
kind message some former employees
buzzfeed news spoke with
also suggest that degeneres needed to
take more responsibility for the
environment
they want to see a change in ellen's
workplace environment
and in tv work environments in general
we reached out to warner media and the
show about the new allegations
both declined to comment warner media
sent a statement before
the article was published saying it was
disappointed that the primary findings
and its own investigation
indicated some deficiencies related to
the show's day-to-day management
it said it will implement several
staffing changes to address the issues
that were raised
jerica jamie thank you